[Music]
we will be in a zero sum world if we
can't grow and increase productivity the
war is fought in Ukraine and I feel like
we are not included at all in today's
politics is the personalization of
politics ukrainians Russians Americans
British and fill in the blank they all
have a responsibility there was an
attempt to commit to truth seeking and
impartiality and objectivity today that
is simply no longer the case there is no
correlation between happiness and
earnings we know that governments as I
said before dropped a ball it becomes
increasingly unequal because that's what
human beings
do what do you think in the current
circumstances uh should be done to
advance peace in the context of the
Russia Ukraine conflict are you saying
that the uh the West should not be
supporting Ukraine at all there should
be no weapons provided to Ukraine what
do you think should be actually done
well we had two conflicting interests
there we had the anxiety of the West
about what the Russians might do and we
had the anxiety of the Russians about
what the West Was likely to do they had
been maneuvering against one another as
was correctly said earlier for many
years militarily in the donbass in the
area nearest the Russian border and
politically and otherwise in all the
usual intelligence as well manuvering
that we know goes on so the issue for me
and I think a reasonable way to approach
it is to say before you get to the point
of the threat of the basic interests of
these two sides that you sit down which
was done early in the conflict back in
February to try to come up with some
solution that might address the needs of
both sides so there is no war rather
than proceed Crossing each other you
know red lines as they like to call them
and then Pro one side provokes the other
and then to retreat into saying who
exactly provoked who when with what date
really that's childish the issue is what
are the fundamental concerns and those
have to be put on the table with a
demand that they be worked out without
military recourse okay I I'm still I'm
afraid not quite sure whether you think
that there should in the in the interim
of coming to an agreement uh diplomatic
agreement with Russia you think there
should be support for Ukraine but let's
turn to S Lana what what do you think
about that uh diplomatic as it were
solution to peace uh first of all Russia
even now they don't want to negotiate
and they repeat it a lot of times that
they're going they're going to have
peace talks only on their terms meaning
that uh the occupied parts of Ukraine
that are are right now under Russian
control that we they will remain Russ r
that Ukraine will have to give up Crimea
east of Ukraine the paria region but not
only that that Ukraine should never
become a NATO member and all of the
other demands that Russia has and when
uh we are talking about the negotiations
between the west and Russia I don't see
there Ukraine I mean the war is fought
in Ukraine and I feel like we are not
included at all like it it sounds like
everything has to be decided over over
us that they will reach some kind of
agreement and but what will happen to
Ukrainian people who are living
occupation who are scared to leave their
houses because their women can be raped
that the kids that can't learn their
language what happened to all of those
people if those lands remained Russian
So my answer for that is Ukraine has to
receive uh the military and financial
support to win the war in a military way
if it is not enough
uh to win the war if you receive not
enough like now Ukraine at least have to
be in the better position before
negotiations it has to have certain
leverage to talk with Russia for example
if we receive long range missiles and we
uh seize Russian army in Crimea and uh
destroy the car bridge then we can talk
with Russia about something or we
destroy their Fleet because right
now both sides won't need negotiate
because Russia of course won't leave
Ukraine's land and Ukraine won't give up
its territories and its people so
Richard you you're you're not taking
into account the interest of the
ukrainians in suggesting a negotiation
between uh the west and
Russia of course I am that that's the
kind of debate that that goes nowhere
finger pointing it's your fault no it's
your fault it's
childish of course Ukraine's interest is
in my mind
the horror of the war that is being
fought mostly on their territory is
self-evident they are suffering
unspeakably and they should not have and
the responsibility for that is
largely distributed all across the
participants ukrainians Russians
Americans British and fill in the blank
they all have a responsibility all of
them to participate in a negoti ated
settlement that takes into account the
the needs the genuine needs of the
Ukrainian people the Russian people and
the Western countries that have inserted
themselves into this Arrangement well
they may they may all have a
responsibility but spit Lana's point is
that the Russians aren't going to take
that responsibility they're not going to
take into account the interests of the
ukrainians and what do you do what do
you propose that you do in a situation
where one party is simply not prepared
to take into account the interests of
the other well we don't read the history
the same the Russians feel that they
have not had their security interests
taken seriously by the NATO Powers by
the United States and Britain that
guaranteed them certain protections with
the end of the Cold War Etc I'm not here
to negotiate or to arbitrate among these
different perspectives but I don't think
it gets us one step closer to peace
to spend our time deciding who's the
good guy and who's the bad guy this
stuff happens in every war and mostly
what it does is obscure the
underlying Productions of this why did
NATO moved to the east why was that a
useful thing to do in the interest of
world peace that's just as important as
what happened in the donbass over the
last eight years all of those things are
reflections of
underlying social
processes obviously you've been privy to
some of the characters that we see on
the news you've spoken to world leaders
you've you you've seen how these people
think sometimes firsthand um what what
are some of the most valuable lessons
that you've personally gained from those
interactions well I mean sometimes
they're very cautionary TS because you
know you really kind of see the limits
um and many of our leaders you know
today I mean I've seen some pretty
inspirational you know people as well at
firsthand but you know there's only so
much one individual can do and I think
you know the biggest risks that we have
in today's politics is the
personalization of politics right and we
see the strongman phenomenon you know on
every Frontier I mean lots of books
being you know written about this you
know for example and it's it's a feature
of our time because you know when you
have a time of Rapid change people
really can't keep up and they're kind of
looking for some mechanism say stop the
world I want to get off or stop the
world I don't want it to change anymore
and it's very easy for individuals to um
uh come forward in that regard and
present themselves as Champions you know
the populist leader but you know they're
very limited and so I mean the things
that I've learned the most is just this
importance of having checks and balances
in system and also to be honest the the
power of people power I mean we've we've
all got ourselves to you know be instead
of followers be more uh active um and
you know think about actions that we can
take and you know what uh the best
leaders are those who actually listen to
other people and really take their
advice on board but we also have to
again understand the limitations of the
political systems that we're in people
are always blaming you know the US for
this or you know the UK for that and you
know our systems themselves are quite
Limited in the information that gets
brought forward I mean it's
extraordinary important to try to find
you know again mechanisms of openness so
that information comes in because you're
only as good as the things that you know
and you know the advice that you can uh
you can take on board and you know and
I've again I've learned you know how
important it is to have good analysis to
have objective analysis you know to
basically bring that forward so to help
people uh make decisions but there is
also then you know the importance of
speaking out when things take you know
pretty a turn pretty negative term yeah
but you know this is a moment where all
of our politics you know kind of across
the world are really jeopardized by this
kind of idea that strong men populist
politicians can really resolve things
and really really what we we do need is
more kind of Grassroots action and
figuring out other ways of giving people
you know Stakes uh stakes in the system
and I mean i' I've taken all that away
from you know being on the inside and
seeing really the limitations right but
I've also seen you know how much things
can be done by small numbers of
dedicated people you know have a shared
sense of mission and responsibility yeah
so I would also you know kind of um make
an appeal for you know thinking more
positively about public service and
Civil Service of you know all kind of uh
a different uh different levels because
again you know governance is only as
good as the people who get involved in
[Music]
it yeah I want to say something to
Martin's observation about the Zero Sum
world in the politics which I think
identifies maybe the central political
challenge for the rest of this century
and when one talks about a zero sum
world in the absence of new gains in
productivity one is measuring the sum in
terms of money in terms of GDP measured
by dollars and as long as GDP is
measured in that way and the sum is
measured in that way we will be in a
zero sum world if we can't grow and
increase productivity and the politics
will be extremely dark for all the
reasons that Martin identifies uh at the
same time there are other ways to think
about the total or aggregate well-being
of a civilization and before 1800 no
civilization would have thought of its
well-being in terms of GDP and there are
ways to lead a positive sum world even
without increasing GDP if we measure the
sums by human flourishing by connections
by the the substantive well-being of the
civilization that we manag to produce
the difficulty is you know if wishes
were horses then Beggars would ride and
the the Zero Sum view the GDP view is
the product of two centuries of
intellectual work of institution
building and of enormously morally and
politically potent cultural development
and identifying that it will become a
problem once growth stops is not the
same thing as constructing the
imaginative alternative that we will
need to survive that problem uh my view
is one of the great tasks of
intellectuals of the moment is to start
working towards that alternative but to
be responsible in that one has to
acknowledge both the enormous moral
achievement of the market-based view and
the fact that we are still living in it
and wishing we weren't won't get us out
of it and denying its accomplishments
won't make us help us to see the
problems that need to be solved as we do
get out of it okay so so sorry Martin
this is really really important because
I think and it's probably a point we
need disagreement so this is uh because
this is an incredibly important issue I
agree completely about the way we frame
GDP and but I won't go into that so in
the all the many centuries before
anybody invented
GDP um what was Society like and I would
say it behaved exactly as one would
expect uh a society with very very
limited wealth and a very limited number
of people who controlled the wealth
Kings and Aristocrats with a few others
to behave they didn't need to know GDP
they knew they wanted everything and the
so one of the most fascinating pieces of
historical research and this is
increasingly now empirically supported
is the the organized societies and I'm
not talking so large states and so forth
in the premodern period were as unequal
as they could be that is to say 80 to
90% of the population uh the people um
Danel was talking about lived on the
more margin of survival and most of them
them were agricultural laborers all
their Surplus was extracted by the top
that was the ultimate Zero Sum society
and it became maximally unequal so my
concern my concern is when we go since
I'm a pessimist when we go to our new
Zero Sum society and I think we' be
moving for it towards it over the last
30 or 40 years it becomes increasingly
unequal because that's what human beings
do and the extractive regime at the top
and there are many examples of this
becomes the dominant mode so while I
would like to believe you know in the in
the this glorious moral Revolution I am
deeply concerned that as we become more
static we go back to the zero sumus of
the 17th 16th 15th century or or ancient
China One of the most extreme examples
in history and that really is something
we have to think about so so this is
extremely important and we agree in some
ways and disagree in others um here's
where we agree one of the things that
the productivity Revolution and the
market societies that produced it have
achieved is to Corral the process of
getting for me into a form that has some
positive product for others as opposed
to the prior ways of doing this which
were purely extractive self-interested
and exploitative and therefore very
damaging so I think we agree about that
um the place where we might disagree and
I don't know how deeply uh you know it's
a little bit old Hegel you know thesis
antithesis synthesis the future cannot
be a return to the Past for all the
reasons Martin identifies and a thousand
others also including that moral
pluralism has led a certain cat out of
the bag that the past controled by
suppressing but at the same time I don't
think we should be trapped in the
tyranny of no Alternatives and think
that the way in which people were before
1800 is the way in which we naturally or
inevitably are uh the way in which
people naturally are is probably the way
in which they ordinarily are that is to
say we're enormously malleable by our
social circumstances and uh it is a
hopeful thing to say that we can create
social circumstances that will shape us
in a way that managed to retain the
gains for cohesion and other regarding
this of productivity Revolution while
discarding what are now the costs
there's no certainty that we can do that
but we have no alternative but to work
in that direction because the
alternative is environmental Calamity
and collapse for all of us let me let me
pick up on one of two things you said
there with with with yanis on that
because we're criticizing Central Bank
as you you three seem to be pretty
unanimous on that but is it that they
are the wrong people or they have a job
that is not possible they are not uh
able to do it because it's it's not a
job that can be done yet well the the
constraints that they're facing they
made a very huge error in the 2000s
before 2008 not to pick up on the
massive private money that was being
minted it was not just that they were
lending money to people they were
borrowing money from themselves in order
to purchase the very toxic derivatives
that they were buying derivatives that
started becoming money and effectively
increasing the money supply so that was
that's where the central banks dropped
the ball in the 2000 after 2008 though I
have sympathy with them because you know
uh it was they were the only game in
town governments as I said before
dropped the ball they they went into
austerity at the time of a massive
recession and the central Bankers were
constrainted on what to do with the
money tree so they plucked the money
tree but the only thing they could do
was to to buy debt private debt and
public debt which was never going to be
plowed into investment in order to
expand the supply for the time when we
needed and John look the the problem was
not inflation we had years of money
printing that was failing to inflation
the reason why we had the inflation with
a supply chain Interruption due to the
pandemic was because we had 10 years of
no investment in the supply side of the
economy due to the inability of the
central bank to do that which I think a
lot of them would want to do was to
which to pluck the money Tre or to
invest in productive capacity not bu
McDonald's bonds right as they were
forced to do right so that that's the
main issue and what happened with the
pandemic of course was that some of the
money had to be given to the little
people at the time when when Supply
chains were disrupted that went up and
that's when they lost control of it they
should have been given the opportunity
by government by Parliament John right
to work together with public investment
vehicle and private investment vehicle
to channel this created money
into the things that would have expanded
the supply of green energy so as to be
able to lessen our dependence here in
Europe to the Europe I agree there was
too much austerity over the previous
decade but I don't accept your your
explanation of of why the the monetary
policy went wrong I me what happened was
the QE was not inflationary because at
the same time that they injected a lot
of QE in mainly by the state bond market
as you say uh the Regulators sometimes
the Central Bank sometimes independent
Regulators were ratcheting down the
amount of credit that commercial Banks
could lend on on the basis of the cash
that was in circulation and because they
wanted a much higher cash ratio for the
commercial Banks to make them more
prudent and recover their balance sheets
it was safe from the inflationary point
of view to put that QE out there as some
kind of counterbalance indeed if they
hadn't put put enough QE out there in in
the middle of the crisis we'd have had
many more bankrupt banks in an even
deeper and longer recession just
recently Federal Reserve board had to
inject um 400 billion I think it was
when the regional Banks started to pop
because money Ty policy is so
[Music]
tight the universities in this country
have completely given up on any pretense
to be objective independent impartial
institutions okay and if you disagree
with that give me one day and I'll give
you a tour of universities and show you
what I mean they've become openly
political organizations and in some ways
that's how they started they started as
very religious institutions that were
pushing an agenda but in the mid 20th
century late 20th century there was an
attempt to commit to truth seeking and
impartiality and objectivity today that
is simply no longer the case ideological
litmus tests are used across the board
if you want to get research grants if
you want to get jobs if you want to get
promoted if you challenge the liberal
consensus if you challenge things like
gender identity Theory opposition to
brexit particular interpretations of
British
history uh you basically will experience
some form of indirect or direct
discrimination and if you want the
evidence of that there's a lovely book
in the tent over there called Val's
voice and virtue which will present all
of the evidence to you and the reason I
point to that is because in way it's
reflective of what's happening in other
aspects of our national life um for
those who do challenge this narrow
Orthodoxy within our um Public Square
that is basically anti-
brexit PR globalization Pro migration
socially liberal um which basically
speaks to about 20% of the country if
you look at the British social attitude
survey uh the latest edition came came
out last week it suggests that 20% of
Britain are strongly and consistently
socially liberal on a whole range of
issues if you challenge some of those
assumptions some of those
beliefs um you are variously told that
you are buying into
misinformation that you are um pursuing
half truths or you have been manipulated
by media and so on and so forth to the
point where even fact Checkers and
reality checks and so on if you look at
them closely are basically becoming
openly partisan is what I would argue
can can can I just just just so if you
if you challenge this
consensus you will find yourself um
essentially being gas lit by many
institutions so if you ask yourself the
question why are so many people
rebelling politically culturally
socially it is because when they look at
these institutions they do not see
people like them who reflect their world
viw what can we do about it we can we
can force open the institutions we can
actually have people in those
institutions who do represent a wider
diversity of viewpoints that might make
you feel uncomfortable but if you
genuinely want to reduce polarization in
society you know we're going to have to
do that and I think that's the great the
true the true power which is you've got
a system which using the profit
incentive rewards people for Innovation
rewards people for creating things and
profit is the reward you get for um
creating a good whose Parts is equal uh
come you've made together is equal more
than the cost of it made to produce so I
think that the the profit motive in the
market system has delivered these these
innovations that have made things like
an iPhone in my pocket with
extraordinary um technological capacity
accessible to the masses so in any
meaningful sense the if you look at the
amount of food you can have or travel
you could do today that would have been
a few hundred years ago unimaginable for
the 99% people even potentially
Rockefeller wouldn't have had the kind
of luxury that that just basically
everyday things well the iPhone didn't
exist well indeed that's the point which
is the the capit system has given us
these great Innovations this is actually
where I get confused by Aaron's whole
philosophy be because he talks about
luxury communism but in fact everything
that he seems to love has come out of a
capitalistic system it's come out of the
innovations that have been driven by
market system funded by the basically
the US taxpayer everything in the iPhone
comes out no that's that is completely
nonsense so that is completely there are
a few specific patents that can be
linked back to some specific
Technologies screens lithium batteries
microprocessor we are not going to make
this about the iPhone so um you can pick
this afterward by all means um I do want
to give Aaron a chance to come back on
this question of inequality but you
mentioned inequality for wrong reasons
what's inequality for Right Reasons if
it's inequality between people who put
in different effort between an
entrepreneur someone who creates
something you know there's there's a
doctor who's working 20 hour days saving
people's lives you know people aren't I
don't think we should expect everyone to
have the same incomes and and the same
wealth precisely and there there that
that that seem would be kind of
dystopian outcome to me so a cleaner
working 20 hours shouldn't be paid the
same as a doctor working 20 hours well I
mean I think the it's not just the
amount of work you do but the value of
the work and the value of what you
create is is you know in some way not
perfectly represented if your income um
but a doctor's obviously spent an
extremely long period of time and is
doing a a very um life you know saving
life-threatening job so uh I mean a
footballer people get a lot of value out
of it you know I wouldn't pay a
footballer 20 million but I think get a
lot of value out of C football um
viewers get a lot of value out of that
um Aaron I want to ask you about
inequality is inequality legitimate and
what role what place should it have
within the systems that you're promoting
advocating
for it's a great question inequality and
of itself I I agree to an extent it
could be something of um a pointless
Obsession clearly if everybody was
earning £60,000 a year and we know
empirically that after £60,000 a year
earnings there is no no correlation
between happiness and earnings we know
that so you could get to a point and
let's not talk about what that would do
to inflation and let's just sort of say
speculatively everybody could earn 60
Grand a year then yeah I can I can see
conditions under which you say fine you
can have a certain amount of inequality
but the conditions we live under at the
moment are rather different to that so
in the United States for instance you
have around 40 million people that need
food stamps to eat right and I I I think
that is unacceptable and I'm not going
to just deploy a moral argument around
that I also sort of deploy a political
theoretic argument so it's two strange
words put together but political Theory
and I would say to people who are
liberals cuz people who are liberals say
the individual is uniquely placed to
determine their own life nobody else not
you Marxist what the state to tell them
I agree that the individual is uniquely
placed to determine their own lives
absolutely nobody else should tell you
how to live what kind of project should
be part of your life who you want to be
absolutely not what they don't
understand however is that for Liberal
ends you need socialist means because if
you don't have access to housing food
Health Care energy if you're freezing
cold in your house you can't think about
reading the complete works of PR right
you can't say oh you know what I'm going
to watch all those Godard films down the
cinema when you go to the ATM and it
says2 200 overdrawn so I think it's
fundamentally important to say that if
you want these higher Goods in life then
clearly you need to remove certain
sources of of
deprivation so like I say liberal ends
impossible that socialist means and
where and I put Matthew in the liberal
tradition I don't think that he would he
would disagree with that I hope not
where I think liberals get things badly
wrong is they say individuals are
uniquely place to determine their lives
yes and by the way we're going to do
economic distribution purely through
markets well that therefore means that
individuals don't have access to the
goods to be the people they want to be
clearly you need a measure of socialism
clearly and all the things you're
talking about inequality falling well
actually for the first 40 50 years of
the Industrial Revolution living
standards don't increase even though we
do have an extraordinary increase in
productivity and and Innovation
absolutely they only start to increase
when you get worker organizing
Collective action people asking for more
money and I find it incredible that
basically your argument is well we got
rid of child slavery laws we got the 8
hour day we got we got the weekend we've
got socialized Healthcare and it's all
thanks to the bosses I mean nobody
thinks that not even the bosses think
that so all the progress yes there's
been a great deal of progress that's
been created by markets technological
innovation absolutely of course there
has I like markets I like technological
innovation much of it by the way by the
US taxpayer which throwing to but at the
same time those those those contractions
in inequality and those improvements in
in in living standards for all of us are
because people fought for
[Music]
them